il trône à proximité de l'a 86 et de la
base aérienne 107 cet appareil de 40
mètres a commencé son travail de forage
du sol à vélizy-villacoublay 120 jours
pour creuser deux puits à 1600 mètres de
profondeur en vue de la construction
d'une centrale de géothermie et
l'inauguration de ce chantier a été
donnée jeudi 27 août une stratégie de
verdissement de la chaleur donc c'est le
premier élément important de ce projet
c'est produire de la chaleur par la
géothermie verte
le deuxième aspect important de ce
projet c'est aussi de fournir une
infrastructure moderne et nouvelle pour
la ville
la géothermie sait capter la chaleur des
sous sols pour la transformer en énergie
qui va alimenter des bâtiments chauffage
et eau chaude sanitaire l'eau extraite
des profondeurs est ensuite réinjectée
dans la nappe souterraine
le procédé va alimenter près de douze
mille foyers béliziens et et industriels
locaux à partir de la fin 2021
il permettra de se passer du gaz pour le
chauffage urbain et d'éviter une hausse
des prix significative
le projet né de deux contraintes le fait
qu'on ait tout chauffage urbain qui
était de la cogénération innovantes dans
les années 70 mais qui étaient issus du
gaz
et puis à bas le faisais rien en fait le
prix du chauffage urbain allait doubler
dans les cinq ans avec la taxe carbone a
noté jcn donc il y avait deux volontés
de la ville ce qui a fait que on a
cherché une solution avec angie le
projet s'est concrétisé par la création
d'une société de production d'énergie
renouvelable velits geodon fait partie
angie est la ville qui a fourni le
terrain
coût total de l'investissement 25
millions d'euros avec des financements
de l'ademe et de la région ile-de-france
qui apporte 3 millions d'euros on aura
beaucoup moins empreinte carbone
et on aura une énergie moins chère avec
une indépendance énergétique des villes
et c'est pour ça que je suis très
heureuse que nous puissions faire ce
premier réseau de chaleur à vélizy après
en avoir fait beaucoup en seine et marne
et dans l'essonne c'est une prouesse
technologique qui j'espère va faire
beaucoup de petits dans les villes des
yvelines
cette centrale de géothermie est une
première dans l'ouest parisien et
intéresse quelques maires yvelinois
présent lors de l'inauguration le
recours à cette technique permettra
d'économiser chaque année l'émission de
près de 23 mille tonnes de co2